whatsapp ai people have to be too soon
the binding of isaac materiale bellico
by sac ragazzi dopo che l'altro episodio
l'ho presa un pò nel deretano per colpa
di difficile sto gioco che ci possiamo
fare
volevo riprovare ragazzi a di zara e
isaac per vedere se riesco a giocare e
trovare nuovi oggetti appunto perché
sono stati city novissimi oggetti nuovi
livelli dopo un disastro ha fatto per
questo nuovo dlc di barney gop isaac col
coso qua magari riesco col roll a
trovare 9 nuove questo ad esempio è una
merda è orribile ricomincia lo so che
farmene
allora ecco vedi che hanno messo l'us
acli file più sanguinosa la porta per la
sanguinosa adesso pazzesca a far ora
hanno fatto un sacco di cambiamenti
l'ultima volta lo prova allora non sono
arrivata mamme sono morto è stato
difficilissimo perché ho fatto cose che
non capivo manco io come cacchio sono
arrivato a mamma perché era un disastro
la mente difficile però mamma mia che
figata
quindi voglio vedere poi chissà quali
sono i boss quelli cazzuti nuovi perché
questi non sono basse cazzotti quelli
che ho fatto finora erano boss normali
sono proprio i boss dei boss quelli che
definiscono il gioco sarebbe veramente
interessante riuscire a finirlo solo che
questa modalità incasinate non lo so a
quella è una cagata
per me male che non lo possono anche
prendere trova schifo ragazzi veramente
il rif
mammamia i pochi rossi sono che si
sparano meno male che ne sono accorto in
tempo volevo prendere questo che non so
cosa sia
sono oggetti nuovi tre giorni fa schifo
questo è lo sciacquone del cesso e fa
ancora più schifo
vediamo è un'attività in che ti
distrugge cioè di sciacqua tutti gli
struggenti mob che ci sono in una stanza
però è una stiva e te non piace
ariete come rigorosa fa rà ming speed a
ok praticamente è più veloce
no basta ce n'è uno che era molto più
che aumentava la velocità del proiettore
quello diamo ai boschi es
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi stanza del
boss number one chi cacchio è brightcove
un anno forse questo c'era c'era o non
c'era bonato migliori il fatto che come
primo posto e imbarazzante che sia così
difficile
c'è chi lascia pure l'alone per terra ma
veramente ciò è possibile che come primo
post ne abbiamo messo una roba così
impossibile
ti lascia pure la donna per terra che
sono tutti vadano cioè tedesca di morire
poi l'ho fatto anche bene non so come ma
ho rischiato grosso
c'è una stanza con lei o questo mi serve
assolutamente subito shot speed up di
empress migliora il sun power
io andrei sotto di qua
tanto ormai non anche capito cosa serve
andare quadro da un pò wine o c'è una
stanza del dado vediamo che da dove tre
ferite ad altre cose che non mi ricordo
cosa fa però la tutti gli oggetti che ci
sono sul piano ok non è male lo userei a
questo punto quando ho finito piano
piano lo usiamo
a madonna rischiato
e veramente difficile o del demonio è
difficilissimo ragazzi ok e devo usare
anche questo perché terrain make non so
chi sia
ho usato meglio rage green power in
perdere uguale pensate rainmaker quello
che fa piovere
mamma mia che difficile sto gioco
diventato veramente difficile ragazzi va
bene ti facciamo vado airola vediamo
cosa mi esce buscemi per favore
brimstone possibile e queste sono quelle
sono le lacrime che ti parlano i
proiettili shader tss non è male però la
città tati mi unisce un po vabbè
prendono ti parlano i proiettili sulle
spari non ti possono colpire non è male
ma sempre abbastanza apprezzato al boss
signori l'ex duke of the flies un
attimino più semplice nei boschi prima
se permettete e siamo allo stesso
livello di prima ci hanno fatto due
livelli prima uguale vede uno sputo in
confronto c'è veramente impossibile con
il piano ragazze che adesso mi si apre
sicuro di nuovo guarda ecco mi sapete
anche stata l'attenzione ts bischoff
fill up non male normale per niente anzi
soprattutto per il fatto il resto dopo
potenziabile lacrime
niente di buono via e io vado qua
ragazzi perché la zona nuova non posso
non andare nella zona nuova ragazza e
devo perciò anche se la più difficile ci
vado accendino guarda al mondo che
pronuncia che vi sembra l'attimo
esagerata come spiegato brevemente anche
solo accendino accende le cose quando
farmi provare delle sue funzioni alla
mia tattica quella di dire
se lo specchio davis per rispondere qua
no c'è da un cazzo
chissà che cacchio di farci questo
specchio nori rolla ho buttato il roll
mannaggia mannaggia ho sbagliato a
schiacciare di morti tarci mia speriamo
che sappiamo di trovare abbastanza
stanze per dire cariche per ricaricarmi
coso qua non entrò perché non ho la
chiave per perderla pregio che sono
veramente un pirla
lei mi ha salvato il culo scilla tr
nice
perfetto allora abbiamo due chiavi sono
veramente un pirla supremo perché ho
buttato il re roll come se niente fosse
vabbè prova entrare lo stesso nella
stanza vediamo cosa provo fa schifo
richiamo quello di da fianco
non ho idea di cosa sia testi rainbow
non so cosa sia ma non me lo trova
proprio cioè non me lo trova nelle dei
database talmente nuovo che non c'è
quindi non so che cazzo a giudicare così
ad occhio sembra che ogni lacrima e
diversa c'è proprio che facciamo un
effetto diverso cioè quindi spaventano
altre tipo fanno più danno c'e niente è
ben quello quello infiamma
ovviamente in base alla lacrima ogni
lacrima è diverso
ce n'era uno simile che ti cambiava ogni
tipo disfare una volta c'è ancora adesso
però questo si cambiava ogni la prima
che non è male perché c'è un sacco di
oggetti c'è un sacco di effetti
abbastanza utili tipo questo non sono
male se cosi non è male ma questo è
veramente figo concerto della madonna
ho preso che l'abbiamo abbiamo dato
veramente di lusso ragazzi ma in oggetto
dell'intesa della madonna non sono anche
come cacchio cacchio è sta roba che mi
lancio asti verbi di merda due ore per
farlo fuori
c'è una vita è tremenda vecchio 5 di
danno era che ciò così tanto da bravo
madonna successe cose non saper spiegare
va bene non ho preso danno non so
neanche come è morto ho bloccato gross
ha occhi occhi o chiocchio minchia che
ci sono i minion design cross grosse un
sacco di merda ottimo beni che ho
sprecato il mio cacchio dire roll e a
quest ora lo potevo usare per regolare
st cagata acqua che è inutile che fa
schifo è veramente insulsa però allora
uno mi aumenta al danno questo questo e
questo ovviamente mi quando sparò
attraverso il cosa diventa in diventa di
mez ditemi che c'è una batteria nello
shop perché non posso buttare così
cacchio solo perché ho sbagliato a
schiacciare non c'è la batteria forse
qua no era mini porca vacca st
minibatteria stupida ma guarda mi rimane
una sana forse fosse come farcela già
faccio ce la faccio perché se vado in
un'altra stanza anche quindi quelle che
le challenge me la fa mentre in una
stanza challenge però va bene se ne
frega ho bisogno di regola non posso più
forte di me lega fa troppo schifo
soggetto no non mi entra
forse sempre qui
è successa una roba che non so spiegare
ok ho sbattuto contro un fuoco per
sbaglio ma sono diventato volo
quindi sì pochi completamente di fanno
volare il piano che a distanza ma no
ok mi sono ricaricato il coso ma scusate
un attimo che cacchio sono diventato del
of tears da una porco ma possibile possa
avere st sfiga ogni volta ai ragazzi è
stato però il gioco e tre parti dietro
suicida fare niente ce la possiamo fare
ragazzi si scrive di col tasto qua sotto
lasciato un commento su quello che pesa
dlc per me è veramente fatto benissimo è
bellissimo c'è troppa roba però devo
capire bene tutto come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo visto belle ragazze
[Musica]